luego de casi tres años de bloqueo
venezuela retiró los contenedores
anclados en el puente internacional
simón bolívar desde este martes el
comercio bilateral entre caracas y
bogotá volver a circular presidente
nicolás maduro no ha pedido anunciarle a
la población del estado táchira
fronteriza con colombia que a partir del
día de mañana estaremos dando apertura
comercial
entre nuestro país la frontera
colombo-venezolana fue cerrada para el
tráfico vehicular en agosto de 2015 por
orden del mandatario venezolano nicolás
maduro en 2019 el cierre se amplió a las
personas con la ruptura de las
relaciones diplomáticas después de que
el líder opositor venezolano juan guaidó
intentaré ingresar desde la localidad
colombiana de cúcuta una caravana de
ayuda humanitaria colombia está
dispuesta también a empezar un proceso
ordenado para que podamos garantizar ese
paso fronterizo pero voy a hacer muy
claro esto no va a ser con chambonadas y
eso no va a ser de manera súbita
da una instrucción a la dian a migración
colombia y a la fuerza pública de tener
todo dispuesto para empezar ese proceso
gradual colombia y venezuela comparten
una porosa frontera de 2.219 kilómetros
y múltiples pasos ilegales donde las
autoridades de ambos países denuncian
actividades de grupos guerrilleros
paramilitares contrabandistas de
combustible o narcotraficantes que
dificultan sus complejas relaciones
comerciales